so there's been an exciting development
I heard about it last night about
Elements 114 and 116 the International
Union of Chemistry a you PAC has decided
that the evidence for the existence of
these elements is now beyond reasonable
doubt so they are officially on the
periodic table
all the super-heavy elements are made by
taking a heavy element often one that is
heavier than uranium in this case for
114 is the element plutonium which is 94
then taking calcium which is element 20
and accelerating the iron of calcium at
a terrific speed and letting it bang
into the target of plutonium once a
month once a week
very rarely one of these millions or
trillions of atoms fuses so you get an
atom of element 114 the problem is then
to prove it the work on element 114 and
116 were part of an international
collaboration between scientists in
Russia in the in Dubna
which is to the north of Moscow and
American scientists in the Lawrence
Livermore Lab in California and they
have come up with some data and some
years ago 2004 so seven years ago they
published papers about these elements
Brady who likes forensic science and
crime says these you can imagine like
witness reports this is what the
scientist saw and they believed that
this is really good evidence that they
have made the elements what has happened
since then is that I you PAC has set up
what they call a Joint Working Party to
examine the evidence rather like a law
court examines the evidence for a crime
and what has happened the breaking news
is that this Joint Working Party has
published a paper here it is and it's in
the journal pure and applied chemistry
which is the Official Journal of IU PAC
and what they have done is look at the
evidence for all the elements from
113 that's the one beyond Cap'n it's ium
right up to 118 the end of the periodic
table at least the end of that row of
the periodic table and they've examined
them all and have come to the conclusion
that the evidence is really strong as
they put it beyond reasonable doubt for
elements 114 and 116 so now we can
include those with certainty in our
periodic tables in fact my coffee cap
seems to rather jump the gun and already
they've got 114 and 116 in color with
holes rounding I don't know who it was
that designed this gap the evidence that
the working party looks at is quite
complicated and I as a chemist I'm a bit
out of my depth here but what they look
at is the way that the scientists detect
the decays of these atoms when they
create an atom it bangs into a target
and then sits in the target and begins
to decay and each time it decays it goes
from one element to another gamma rays
energetic waves given out and these are
detected so you can see here the energy
of the different gamma rays that have
been detected all sorts of decays have
been discovered for elements from 113 up
to 118 but so far the committee is
really convinced by the evidence for 114
and 116 what should we what about the
others
it doesn't mean that they're wrong it
just means that there's still a bit of
doubt and people either need more time
to think about it or we need some more
experiments before we can be absolutely
certain so what's going to happen now to
140 and 106
at the moment these elements have the
symbols uuq and uuh which are
essentially the Latin for 114 and 116
and what will now happen is that these
elements all being well will receive
proper names that the teams whose
evidence has been accepted will begin to
think about names though there may be
some delay before the names come up but
what is certainly true is that because
this is done by an international
collaboration that there will not be any
nationalistic name and it will be used
to honor probably the name of one as a
scientist I still quite like plank iam
as a name but my views are not important
here so these decayed chains a very
specialist you might expect that you
just see them in the paper we've even
been watching carefully you'll see that
I've got a tie with them on it and you
can get a time with these decay chains
to celebrate the discovery of some of
these elements this one came from damn
start from the GSI where elements
hundred and twelve hundred ten hundred
and eight were made and so all being
well there's gonna be a new tie for
elements 114 and 116 and I hope I'd be
given one of them too